une automotrice cui jian isolation on
était donc là voilà je m'étais fait
défoncer par hélène là bas j'avais même
crucial que était mon pénis alors que
non il est plus grand encore j'ai une
très bonne nouvelle pour vous parce que
là en fait je reviens donc de ces de ce
[ __ ] de truc en rond voilà la carte
magnétique était dans la salle à 29 j'ai
réussi à revenir jusqu'à là et a
sauvegardé
on n'a plus qu'à sortir et à retourner à
revoir le mec des à sa ville trop chaud
quoi à l'entente bat estac aller oui je
sais pas du tout ce nous mêmes malo il
faut la lienne il peut me suivre et non
pas à telle est la question
ben voilà je suis là en plage vous
saviez que cette chose était ici ouais
c'est son bien c'est zéro tu sais c'est
bon maintenant il descend au dispensaire
navré de vous en faire
ensuite on pourra utiliser la carte
d'accès production d'un dispensaire et
la dépêche toi il va calmement quoi moi
j'ai frôlé la mort je me suis pour
embrocher lui s'en fout il marche comme
ça j'ai même vu envoyer un sms en même
temps alors on va faire un truc déjà on
va sauvegarder
donc je suppose que ça va être vers
l'ascenseur ah ben il est là regardez le
tum ouvre là je vais ramasser le times
elles vont partir dépêche toi mon gars
va pas au camping la bâche et maman et
papa mais sow balistique ou regarder
j'espère que tu vas mo o j'espère que tu
vas mourir
oh merde au [ __ ] alors premier réflexe
au plat calmement moi quand je souhaite
que quelqu'un meure s'installer même
avant je suis ma phrase ramos à
l'ascenseur on a les cartes allait pas
bon ben amos à l'ascenseur voilà oui ça
fait plaisir un à l'émission suivante on
est chauds la [ __ ] je me calme un
petit peu ok je me calme type alors
trouver un kit d'urgence
bien évidemment la lienne et là je
suppose dans ce car tout par exemple
avant toute chose prendre le temps de
sauvegarde et bonjour les cadavres sava
vinckier d'urgence voilà voilà donc ça
c'est l'indication de l'allier
désolation trouver un kit d'urgence dans
ce périmètre de 800 mille mètres carrés
il est juste là le mec 1
oh non mais la grenade aveuglante qui me
fait peur là il ya un petit conduit
peut-être qu'on va y aller on va devoir
y aller
rétablir le courant roche un taser un
thriller comme on dit dans le milieu
bah oui à 6 calibur et scali taser
nickel est alors maintenant que tu
cherches peut l'éloigner avec çà ou là
ok même heure et demie alors là c'est
sûr et certain à metz j'ai cassé un one
shot quoi je peux faire qu'une seule
fois j'ai qu'une munition enclenché la
réfrigération bah oui voyons bien sûr
que oui
un mail au hockey le manque une c'est ça
c'est ça ce qui se passe et qu'il en
manque une la verrouiller vos fonctions
la dernière [ __ ] de bonbonnes qui va
juste là alors vous allez me dire où
aller cette [ __ ] de bonbonnes
mordelles alors moi je vais m'arrêter
ici et je vais trouver la [ __ ]
eaubonne
donc je peux accéder à cette chambre
mais pour l'autre il ya pas la deuxième
bande réfugiant dans ses pas y aller
voilà mais bon là comme axa celle ci ce
qui est formidable
ah mais chez au milieu des cadres havre
en a partout comment t'appelles-tu
jackson va t'appeler cent et un truc ce
prénom mais merde quoi mais chaussé
faire quoi ici à abala deuxième homme a
aimé la ligne hop et r j'ai hâte à dire
mon gars je te taz on va tranquillement
y aller à reculons comme ça a comme un
petit canard dans un vaisseau perdu au
milieu de l'espace temps hop là juste là
insérez un os pour accéder à cette
chambre il est là regardez on vient de
sauvegarde et il est derrière nous mais
on va tâcher il élabore regardez
regardez on le voit ya eu des dalits
dinde ou comment ça va ah ah ah ya une
vie qui nous sépare bitches
allez on va arrêter de faire les malins
maintenant alors accès au conduit ben
voilà bonjour chers conduit comment vas
tu moi ça va je rentre dans toi tu me le
permet ménage tenant pas ton avis des
gens sans primes et aux oies à temps
mais l'on va sur le toit du vaisseau
regarder comment cette échelle est
longue
ça ne s'arrête plus cet immense bien
tous les phoques de troyer sur le
vaisseau va y aller on peut y aller
n'ayons pas peur mais pourquoi on aurait
eu peur bah oui voyons on attendait
qui va là je possède le taser allez
allez allez plus vite que ça tu
accélères amanda rifle et s'il te plaît
aulas comme au sauna stukas best way je
te passe directe d'une mèche au taz
non non je mets que voici un ordinateur
et attend ce matin quatre pattes ou
bureau est déjà en accès à l'ordinateur
s'il te plaît énoncé du rapport
enregistré le 13 novembre 2137 à aux
cinématiques ça me plaît et si les gars
officiers médical supérieur de
sébastopol mais je veux chez leur
boucher
cette femme a besoin d aide cette femme
avait besoin ce qui se passe si j'avais
passé il avait planté quelque chose à
l'intérieur d'elle ok d'accord suis
tellement navré s'ils pouvaient france à
savoir ce qu'il allait se passer après
l'été a prêté par d'alien et en gros le
il portait le le patient porter le bébé
de la lienne en gros et c'est comme ça
du coup là il s'est retrouvé dans le
vaisseau chercher un kit de soin blocs
opératoires bah oui oui c'est bien
évidemment ce que je veux un toujours
plus jamais ça omer mais là on fait
comment ça m'énerve qu'on l'entende
alors qu'il est au dessus [ __ ] j'ai
l'impression quand il n'est pas au
dessus alors si en plus on accorde au
dessus ça suffit
c'est par là je pense oh oh oh oh
billy talent voilà on a plutôt heures on
a plutôt heures pour élever sa olalalala
quasi un casier un casier non non non
non non non non non non tu adores via la
ramette octet cupides mais qu'est ce qui
fait qu'aucun au nom il allait à une
pâle - vitesse de sauvegarde
oui bon donc ça c'est fait ça qu'est ce
que ça dit ok on au vert ce truc à
l'aide du code qui était donné dans
l'ordi alors il ya quoi
une carte magnétique sûrement pour une
porte oui on arrive ça me laisse la
dacquoise autres hier un origami voilà
moi je voulais l'origami plutôt que la
carte s'est désolé et ben y'a plus qu'à
trouver la porte qu'on peut ouvrir avec
la carte magnétique on vient de ramasser
on est bon au oui à noyal aliens oui on
a réussi à revoir aliens
c'est un vrai cauchemar et si samuel sa
balawi là c'est clair que boîte à
couches minces un [ __ ] de cauchemar au
ya un mec zf nous ne sommes pas seuls
bienvenue à android landes mais le
second parc d'attractions c'est comme
disneyland ya deux parcs d'attraction
est-ce que je me retrouve face à un
android
en fait c'est peut-être les embrouilles
convient de passer des humains je crois
et les vivants pas lui waouh ta faute
mais j'aime pas trop ce vaisseau salut
salut pied très belles chaussures alors
qu'on a tous droit ouais mais avant il
ya un an dit juste là
ah non au revoir aux espaces mais qu'est
ce qui se passe là où je suis mais moi
j'étais sur mon ordinateur
tranquillement et rue mais non il est
parti mais non mais attendez j'ai pas
compris ce qui s'est passé là moi
j'étais sur l'ordi jouer aux démineurs
et je me retourne et je vois un allié
but de mai quoi quoi quoi
alors est ce qu'il ya des trucs sur eux
oui merci
on va peut-être pas les voir le deuxième
est pas une sauvegarde partout hasard si
elle allait nommer un cocktail molotov
dans les dents et on court plus vite que
si notre surveillant au collège nous
avait prié en train de faire des pétards
dans la cour oui ce que j'aime pas ça
fait de la fumée un chien sur mon écran
savoir prendre ça voilà alors où est là
le truc urgent il est là samuel j'ai les
médicaments même regard des proches des
varices et de source médicale
oui et donc c'est ce que ça veut dire
que je vais mourir tu réponds moi juste
à ces [ __ ] de questions ça me va
sauvegarder juste là alors vous allez
mon gars faut retourner là bas donc bah
je pose qu on y accède par l'un à faut
peut-être c'est pas la centrale
électrique finalement est-ce que c'était
pas la centrale électrique qu'il fallait
passer dites-moi kouici vous plaît dites
moi que oui dites moi s'il vous plaît si
vous ne dit pas oui devant votre
ordinateur mais sachez qu'ils ne se
passera rien je serais pas content et je
le saurai ah oui je pense que c'est pas
la déplacer le concert de mika les bars
et le sommet de rire une sortie et
d'activer la procédure d'évacuation de
l'hôpital bah c'est très bien et je fais
ça pas comment on commet comment je fais
ça là oui ça va attirer la lienne c'est
sûr regardé brune ça fait qu'est-ce qui
se passe waouh l'afoc
oui très bien et alors ensuite quelques
comment ça se passe on fait un
chiffonnier celui qui gagne elle doit
partir c'est ça de l'autre côté aussi
doit on avoir une jupe en soie regardez
là il y en a une aller à mon arrivée
allez allez allez
et un et deux et trois zéro vous
hop là on a pris les devants avec julie
de trucs et maintenant qu'est ce qui se
passe comme moi de brouillard d'aliette
s'il te plaît what what what what
tu as fuck mais il sort d'où croyez
encore oui ça va oui pas maintenant tu
es toi mais ça va bien at inquiète pas
l'apn souvient on va sauvegarder au non
non non non non c'est moi qui courent
pas de justesse je m'en fous j'ai
sauvegardé un question à faire mon gars
moi je mitraille la toux chez eux parce
que je sais que ça va bouger regarde
hop là tu dégages monga bingbing dtc
attentes autant athema dans la tête
haute
c'était bon j'ai gâché toutes mes balles
mais j'ai tué un android c'est la fête
[ __ ] battue avant tout voilà revenons
donc maintenant à nos esprits assez là
c'est juste là je crois que j'appuie sur
le bouton et j'accède là un pin pin
pas du tout c'est ça la dernière
dis moi que c'est ça oui qu accepter et
maintenant droits d'administrateur
obtenu aller lance la procédure
d'urgence
non non non non non non non qu'est ce
qui se passe qu'est ce qui se passe
qu'est ce qui se passe
qu'est ce qui se passe qu'est ce qui se
passe qu'est ce que c'est que ça alors c
ou c ou les dix mois par roussey oui le
conduit au c'est un de voyage dans le
conduit que nous sommes en train de le
faire
on est dans les entrailles du vaisseau
je touche sur l'intestin grêle
j'arrive samuel c'est là où on sort en
escaladant et maintenant je sais où
allez allez allez allez à face à la
vienne j'aurais pu mourir c'était comme
ça aurait dû aller me dis allez allez
vas-y vas-y fais
ah mais c'est vrai que la sauvegarde
c'était ça alors on ne se retrouve ici
voilà on sent le mec qui me lisez là
c'est à droite puis à gauche plus encore
à gauche alors on va y aller en espérant
qu est pas un [ __ ] d'alien toujours si
le laisse pour un cocktail molotov mais
sur ce son grand crâne mais je me cache
il est détendu et il est là il est là
hein j'ai eu beau réflexe
ah oui et regarder à qui appartient ce
cas zelaya une photo d'une fille nue sur
une plage ça plaît pas du tout aux mais
qu'est ce qu'il fait ici lui médias a
fait toi [ __ ] par la vienne je te
souhaite de crever dans d'atroces
souffrances
viala viennent aux mains c'est bon c'est
bon
cinématiques oh non
qu'est ce qui va se passer qu'est ce qui
va me sauver au quai pas ça c'est même
la lienne m'a pas tué parce qu'il s'est
passé ça si ça doit être dur quand même
ah ouais d'accord moi au la beauté de l'
incendie et nous on est là on est libre
et comme ça nous mêmes
échappez vous je couds c'est fermé à
gauche salue à temps je prends le temps
de chercher ce qu'il a voilà c'est
parfait par où c'est par là où par où je
m'échappe par là je peux pas portes
fermées pas par allah a arrêté et
vilains par la barre où je m'échappe pas
cette photocopieuse non elle et moi s'il
vous plaît partout ah non c'est une
blague
non c'est une blague non c'est une
blague mais au nom je crois qu'un ali qu
atomic ça va faire boum et qu'ensuite on
me dira débrouille toi avec cette corde
et ce stylo bic on se réveille alors en
milieu des cendres sans savoir quoi
faire ni eau
non je crois je me vois trois jeunes non
c'est une blague je crois pas si c'est
ça c'est la plus grosse blague de
l'année
ouah ouah à aller [ __ ] fois l'échelle
et dégagent océan te allez tu fais un
effort la mandarine et s'il te plaît
fais pas semblant pas avoir de muscles a
laissé comme un intervilles sauf que là
c'est pas toi qui tient la barre celle
qui te tiens au nom on sait vraiment où
wall et amanda championne d'intervilles
on l'applaudît bien fort si vous fermez
vous voyez ça va le faire m n'est pas
quand ce tournoi ya la vienne non c'est
bon samuel je rêve de te faire un câlin
elle mais ça me dit moi quand on m'en de
cette échelle y aura samuel qui sera là
à genouilly avec une bague de
fiançailles
j'en rêve j'en rêve non y avait juste à
gros trous noirs aïe
oui alors où suis-je bonjour on y est où
on a réussi à s'échapper
ah ah ah ça fait du bien on aura passé
tellement de temps dans cette zone
[ __ ] alors quand est-ce qu'on peut
enfin sortir de ce vaisseau il vivre
retournez voir taylor avec le matériel
médical ah ouais mais c'est vrai que là
il faut il faut aller voir taylor ho ho
ho y'a quoi là-bas ouais c'est vous
[ __ ] oh merde j'ai un teaser attention
je peux tu as they en toute liberté il
n'y a plus la police pour m'arrêter
alors au un peu de camelot avant de
tomber et c'est parti alors rousse aux
sauvegardes
il manque un morceau ils font cours et
part ça je m'en bats les steaks ça il ya
des humains débile regardez bien vous
savez convient de sauvegarder et de ne
pas dire plus ce qu'on va arrêter cette
vidéo là on va lâcher nauder un haut
plateau décède alors attendez mais non
et voilà j'en suis fière fin de cet
épisode de 6 sur à l'isolation j'espère
que vous a plu si c'est le cas comme
d'habitude n'hésitez pas aimé la vidéo
ce fut long difficile [ __ ] c'est
vachement dur ce jeu sans déconner il
est tout le temps à te suivre comme ça
la lienne ce retour très vite dans une
nouvelle vidéo jeux comme quoi je
m'approche de la caméra peut-être parce
que ça fait une heure et demie je joue
et ayem a tué aussi 128 x sont installés
dans une nouvelle vidéo tient tout le
monde
[Musique]
et